if two masks are better than one are
three masks better than two
are four mass better than three
we've got a section that i have
attentively titled here follow the
science but not that science you fool
um so we have uh published this oh
actually i guess
a little over a week ago um a wall
street journal
opinion piece and op-ed you can just
show it very briefly here zach
called the universal vaccination chimera
tools for stopping variants are limited
and
like masks and distancing vaccines are
not a panacea
by a guy named joseph a ladapo who is an
associate professor at the med school
ucla
uh so i came to i just in the last week
i
found this because he and this piece
were
being discussed as if he was an
anti-vaxxer and increasingly i distrust
the assessment that someone is an
anti-vaxxer just like i now distrust the
assessment someone is a racist or a
fascist or alt-right or a nazi or you
know
transphobe or any of these ridiculous
epithets that are used to shut down
discussion
and sure enough this piece is not
anti-vaccination
at all it is saying basically um
that um we need a
multi-pronged approach to deal with this
pandemic and that masks are some of the
solution
and that uh distancing or some of the
solution and that vaccines are not going
to be
a magic bullet a panacea in his language
and so just to read
and you don't have to show my screen
here zach although i guess you could
have no
um the last two paragraphs of this wall
street journal op-ed
are other forces pushing mortality lower
the cdc estimates that approximately 83
million americans contracted covet 19
through december
reinfection risk is low for at least six
to nine months following infection
and just taking out of not quoting
anymore
six to nine months because that's how
long we know that's that's the
that's the length of time that we have
data for this at this point so you know
in line with our earlier discussions
about vaccines where we really really
really hope these mrna vaccines are
awesome
that they have long-term safety but we
cannot know yet similarly we cannot know
about long-term reinfection risk for
coping 19.
to continue quoting from this wall
street journal
op-ed from february 4th ladapo says
there is also growing scientific
evidence for outpatient therapies such
as ivermectin
colchicine fluvoxamine and the
politically charged hydroxychloroquine
as well as better hospital practices
a sharp decline immortality will give
rational thinking a bigger stage
allowing schools to reopen and social
and economic activities to resume
it will also liberate american society
from the fear-fueled decision-making
that has dominated the pandemic response
which isn't that again what we should
all be looking for here
a reduction in fear which is fueling
a just insane level of incoherence in
terms of the policies that we are seeing
so
two two pieces of evidence from this
week about the ridiculosity
yes the ridiculosity of the responses
that we're seeing
here we have zach if you would show
briefly from february 10th three days
ago
uh officers at dorm's outdoor exercise
ban
this is a terrible headline uc berkeley
extends dorm lockdown with stricter
mandates so
the message here is okay this is a
terribly headlined article zach if i may
um so i can see my own notes
on this um uc berkeley you know the
one of the shining jewels of the uc
system um has
banned solitary outdoor exercise
in order to tamp down the pandemic
i guess but that means people are now
locked in their dorm rooms with
circulating air that they are sharing
with other people
yeah it's almost certain that that
policy will do
harm to some people because some hours
that would have been spent not in close
contact with others
um will be spent in
encapsulated with them without getting
any fresh air without getting any
exercise
without seeing any other human beings
perhaps without making vitamin d so this
is
absolutely going to interfere this is
actually going to make people sicker
would be my prediction yeah
yes and just the second piece of
ridiculousity
in terms of how how efforts are
proceeding to affect behavior
i'll set this up by saying um
increasingly
when i'm out on walks
even if i'm not within six eight 10 12
20 feet of people
um and i have my mask in my hand clearly
ready to put it on if i do have to be
close to people
um i am you know i've said this for
months now but i get you know i get the
stink guy from people for not actually
being outside wearing a mask and you
know it's winter here it's actually
really wintery here right now and i want
it's it's healthy it's not just i want
but it is actually healthy for me and
everyone will be healthier if
they get exposure to the actual elements
on their
skin and in the winter your face is one
of the few places that you can get that
so
um why are people so confused i mean in
part it's because people feel
virtuous and on the right side of
history
for yelling at other people for not
wearing masks
this is this is unfortunately the
landscape we're in and it comes from a
place of fear
and confusion but that doesn't make it
any easier to deal with so this week i
received
um the oregon coronavirus update
um again on february 10th and zack um so
this is just the web version of it so
that
um so that you guys don't see the actual
email but it's the same thing campaign
reminds us masks save lives
here's one picture cindy is a wildland
firefighter from southern oregon she
wears
masks to protect her she wears a mask to
protect her crew from copen19
just like she protects oregonians from
fires okay i don't see anyone else in
that picture but
whatever i'm not going to focus here
this seems likely to not be the thing
that is
uh necessary here but if you know with
her crew sitting in close quarters
okay but the next picture here is ethan
is a rancher and pro bull rider from
eastern oregon who wears his mask that
we can
so that we can return to normal life as
soon as possible and this picture for
those of you listening and not observing
is a vast sort of
eastern oregon chaparral escape
endless rolling hills for as far as the
eye can see
one person on a horse no other people no
other horses no
other anything that might be
transmitting this virus
and this guy's wearing a mask and we are
being shown this picture
as evidence of how much he cares about
us
and is evidence that this is going to do
anything
to reduce transmission of covid i have
looked
i may have missed it please please
please share it
with me somehow if there is
new evidence that any of these new
variants or even the older variant can
spread outside
we covered in i think april the evidence
that was already out at that point
extensive evidence
that this virus is not transmitting
effectively outside and certainly if
there's no one around where could you
possibly be getting it
right why why are we getting this insane
advice
it is about widespread behavior control
i don't i don't frankly care if it comes
from a place of really feeling good
about trying to help people and just
being really confused
the effect is widespread behavior
control and those of us who are not
interested
in behaving in ways that confused
authorities tell us to do
are now occasionally getting yelled at
by our neighbors when we are outside
actually getting the wind and the sun on
our face so
what's driving me crazy about this is
that
the advice is low quality
and it has this kind of defect to it
where the assumption is
well it can't hurt right right exactly
and the answer is of course it can hurt
right to the extent that people are
being driven crazy by lockdowns and
don't want more of it
you want to give them as much of a
reprieve as you can to the extent that
outdoors when you're not near other
people
is safe then the point is hey take your
mask off the official advice ought to be
when you are not around other people
outdoors take your mask off
right and if we should put it on when we
pass each other on the trail even though
there is frankly no evidence that that
is dangerous
okay but um you know look the model that
we built up
was doesn't seem to transmit outdoors
that gives us
a loophole that we can exploit for
better psychological health greater
vitamin d
creation all of those positive benefits
right
we ought to protect it because it could
evolve
to transmit outdoors it's one of the
things that i would actually expect and
the way to prevent it from doing that
is to actually be more cautious than we
should be
put masks on when we're you know
standing in the ski line or whatever
even though there's no evidence that it
transmits in in those circumstances and
it didn't seem to have that that
evolutionary move did not seem to happen
in the wake of the
massive regular protests from last
northern summer
right but in any case a rational
course would be the place where we know
you're safe is when you're not around
other people
outdoors and not around other people
might mean 12 feet away right
right 12 feet away you can afford to
have your mast down and not you know
scowl at the other person for
you know not wearing a mask whatever it
is we can afford that reprieve the risk
is really really low
as we get closer where it's more
plausible that something could
jump we should be protective of the
loophole so that it doesn't disappear on
us but we should not pretend that the
point is i'm actually exposing you
to you know a risk just because we're
standing near each other outdoors so
the policy is just i'm also i'm sorry i
interrupt you but
like i'm also really concerned about
caving to other people's fear i
and you know the fear is being generated
and and
curated and augmented by by government
officials frankly
and by you know these government
officials at the state level and at the
federal level and i assume elsewhere in
the world as well
but then you have a populist that is
increasingly just
fearful and disregulated and
can't remember what normal was and is
frankly having an ever harder time
imagine that normal will ever be back
and in those conditions especially
really anytime
but in those conditions especially i
don't
i think it's actually even more
dangerous to say i get that you're
scared i will just
let your fear drive our behavior no
that's like that's the mistake of
safetyism
on campuses of trigger warnings of all
of the stuff
that created a whole dysregulated unable
to figure out how to move forward in the
world popular
uh generation of sort of you know the
second half of
of millennials and you know again just
caveat
we happened to be teaching college for
like the entire millennial generation
and almost to a person the students we
met
didn't need that stuff they didn't ask
for it and when we said that's not how
what we're going to do
we're going to treat you with respect
and we're going to challenge you i'm
going to show you things that you don't
like
and that challenge your preconceived
ideas and we're going to expose our
biases and your biases and all of that
and guess what people actually ended up
educated and less fearful
and more capable in the world and why
the hell
are we asking an entire really global
population at this point
to fall prey to the same garbagey
garbagey ideology that is clearly
causing higher ed to fail
well and at some level to the extent
that we push
nonsensical and by nonsensical i mean
doesn't match the
empirical evidence uh mask policy yeah
we are going to cause rebellion against
it you don't want to give
people who are anti-mask for example
more of a point than they should have
and to the extent that you're advocating
things that don't make sense
um you're doing exactly that now i got
taken to task this week
i tweeted something i never know which
tweets are going to take off but this is
one of my
most popular tweets ever okay though i
expected it to go
not very far my tweet was something like
um if double masking uh
is that much is so protective why aren't
they built that way in the first place
now this was an honest question right
because a
i don't buy that double masking is good
that does not mean
that there are not combinations of masks
that would be better but here are the
questions that immediately arise in this
context
okay kovid is a
is transmitted it's a respiratory virus
it's not it's the reason that we have
masks for the protection of
people in the context of respiratory
viruses is
covid different in some way that two
masks are good for covid and not for
other things that are transmitted this
way in which case that's interesting
but i want to see that i want to say oh
we've been making masks wrong the whole
time
lots of people have been getting sick
even though masks were used because the
mask should have been twice as thick
and then we should make them twice as
thick go ahead
uh so my my only rejoinder to you and i
think we did this over the dinner table
in fact
was the one reason the one analysis that
i have seen
for the conditions under which two masks
might be better than one well i guess
two one
is that the mask that you were wearing
was a low quality mask to begin with
and in order to make a single high
quality mask you just want to double up
too low quality masks they're low
quality in different ways
okay great also why don't you just get a
high quality mask so like that's
that's one answer and for um
you know for me i'm wearing these masks
that my mother is making thank you
and they're they're wonderful and they
have two layers of cloth and they have a
layer
of of additional i can't remember what
the specifics are mom
um you know of additional stuff in
between the two cloth layers and they
fit my face really well
and they're comfortable and they're
awesome and you can't tell by looking at
it that it's not just
a cheapo single cloth layer mask and
that's
maybe unfortunate but i know that i'm
walking around when i'm masked and it is
you know every time that i'm around
strangers and anytime i'm indoors it's
not our home
um that i'm wearing a single high
quality mask the one
the one place that i see um
even if you've got two high-ish quality
masks
is that if they fit your face
somewhat differently and each of them is
a slightly imperfect fit
that potentially having the mask that
fits better on top of the mask that fits
worse can basically help
it conform to your face better that's
great then we need it then we need the
information to be given to you so that
you can figure out whether double
masking is better because here's the
problem
okay if two masks are better than one
are three masks better than two are four
mass better than three
right there will come a point i
guarantee you
there will come a point at which extra
masks start working against you because
what they do is reduce the ability of
air to transmit through them so it will
go around
now my point would be if you take a high
quality mask that fits you
well and you layer another high quality
mask on top of it you are probably
reducing its effectiveness
therefore it is not true that two masks
are better than one it's true that some
combinations are better than a single
mask of some type
right but without telling us that
saying actually double masking might be
a good idea right
you are going to create again this is
another case where you are going to
create
more disease just like telling people
they shouldn't exercise outdoors
alone right you are going to create more
disease because they're going to do
something else
so you have to tell us what it is that
we are trying to optimize so that we can
operationalize it
rather than you know come up with some
overly simplistic
idea like two masks are better than one
where we can now start scowling at
people who are only wearing one mask
right that is destined to do harm and
the fact that
um that we we aren't having the
conversation right
right it's clear what the pattern is
you've got you had one mask
now we're being told to can we fast
forward and
find out what you're going to say about
three right we ought to know everyone
wants simple rubrics
and um especially because this is
confusing
and i would argue some of this is
intentionally confusing this is being
made more confusing than it need be for
reasons that
um i will remain agnostic on for now
um a friend of ours told me a story this
week that she experienced
several weeks ago in which she's in a
grocery store
and there's some dude with a you know
imperfectly fitted mask
who was on his phone the whole time
talking loudly through his phone when
therefore you know talking we know
spreads viral particles much more than
being quiet
talking loudly presumably because he's
talking through his mask
and he's picking up all this produce and
putting it down and yes filmmates don't
seem to be a big cause
like you know most of us are trying to
be a lot more careful about not handling
a lot of stuff that we're not actually
gonna buy
in stores so he's picking up all his
produce and he's talking loudly on his
phone the whole time
and he's presumably his own little you
know if he if he was sick
he was spreading this stuff and so as
um they happened to check out around the
same time
and as she was preparing to go out into
the winter weather
she had to adjust something here and
briefly took off her mask in order to
get herself adjusted and he walked by
and saw her
and voiced a nasty snarky comment about
how
masks are keeping us safe and why
doesn't she care
it was the guy who was behaving uh
despicably frankly yeah you're right
it's it's the simple rubric
it's the simple rubric problem the fact
that he was wearing a mask and behaving
in every single other way
badly with regard to how to reduce the
chances that if he were sick he was
going to get other people
sick didn't affect him at all it's like
it didn't enter into his world view
and he could still feel all high and
mighty whenever he sought anyone who was
for a moment doing the one thing that we
are told we all must do if you care
about your friends and neighbors
so those of us who can think i think are
having a problem
with a complete failure to do any
net analysis right there is a sense that
um that which might help is
should be policy right well it might be
that somebody is going to catch the
virus from you
outdoors while you're exercising alone
so let's have you not do that with no
understanding that you will therefore do
something else where it's more likely to
get transmitted right
so the point is this is a at best
well-intended policy that is likely to
kill
right um i would argue that the two mask
thing is too
does that mean that most people's mask
choice wouldn't be better doubled
it might well be but we need to know
what we're optimizing
before we know whether or not we should
double our mass if you're wearing a mask
of one of those vents in it
i'd like you to double mask because
those masks the vents in them they don't
protect the rest of us at all
right like there are some masks that are
crap and no one should be wearing them
[Music]
right